all right we're drafting now the best
games of 2021 now that we have the full
schedule trying to be sensitive to our
friends watching on sky sports
chris ask me the trivia question okay
here we go who was the last defending
super bowl champion to lose their season
opener
who was it mike last defending champion
a loser season opener
why are you asking me so quick because i
want you to mess it up and get it wrong
that's why i'm trying to put the
pressure on you
it wasn't last year because the chiefs
beat the texans the year before that the
defending champion didn't play in the
opener
the year before that who was it
it was the pa the patriots lost to the
chiefs at some point the patriots i'm
just gonna say the patriots you are
correct
was it the chiefs game yes it was it was
that the cream hunt
right that he fumbled early on and then
like tore them up and then had like
500 yards after that right okay uh well
this one's easy some days it doesn't
matter if you have the first
pick some days it does yes this year the
best game
by far week four sunday night football
nbc
tampa bay buccaneers at new england
patriots tom brady's last game ever at
gillette stadium and if he
starts the season on the same pace he
was adhering to last year
he will break the all-time career
passing yardage record
in new england as he will be it will be
a king's return i it will be
i think embarrassing how much he gets
cheered i really do chris
i know it's it's interesting i would
think so too now there is that boston
fan base that's like still mad that he
left the patriots and all that
so are they mad at him are they mad at
bill belichick no i think there's some
that are mad at him
i've saw that throughout the year you
know not mad but like you know like like
hey i'm a patron i'm not gonna root for
the bucks like that kind of thing but
i'm with you i would think it would be
one of these weird games where
they're literally making crowd noise for
him not to
you know get a first down or a touchdown
and he throws a touchdown and they cheer
just for him
this is the last time they're gonna see
him in uniform in person and it's the
last time he'll be back
until they retire his jersey and hang it
from the rafters i i think they're going
to give him
yeah greatest nfl player of all time
they're going to give him the respect he
deserves i really do think that it will
be over the top to the point where
bill belichick will be very anxious to
go home and get under the covers
yeah no i would expect that and i think
like really
you know again bill i think will be in
favor of rolling out there
he might love it roll out the red carpet
for tom
let's make him emotional let's make him
think about everything other than the
football game
let's do all of that right there's a
belief within the patriots organization
that when tom is too emotional that's
when
he's not as effective right as he needs
to be all right what do you got well i
can't let you
corner the market here all right so i'm
gonna go with the packers and the chiefs
says my next one yes because it's
jordan love yeah versus chad henny
they're right i'm going with that one
yeah i mean i'm sure hoping rogers is a
starter in green bay there but
uh yeah i want to see that as we talked
about earlier i mean to me
it's i think it's rogers who's you know
i hold as the greatest quarterback ever
mahomes is as talented as we've ever
seen and maybe could be the greatest
quarterback ever i mean so
that's where i want to see it we haven't
seen this match up they have a similar
magician-like style as far as how they
play the position
and i think it would really be kind of a
personal like i want to one-up you
type of thing so that's that's my first
pick
hey and and this next game isn't getting
nearly the hype that it
should it's week five right sunday night
football
bills at the chiefs rematch of the afc
championship game
that moment where stefan diggs was out
there watching the chiefs get the lamar
hunt trophy
you know they played the regular season
last year it was kind of an uninspiring
game it was one of those games it got
shifted around on the schedule didn't it
was it already scheduled for a monday
night no it was not right
it was an early monday night game and
then something came on after it
it was raining right it was blah and
look the and the chiefs have a tough
schedule to start the year
i think the bills are going to want to
show that they're ready to compete with
the best
in the conference and and that will be i
think a physical tough
hopefully exciting game so that to me is
one of the best ones of the year yeah i
i
that would have that probably would have
been my next pick if you didn't take it
i mean come on my homie your homie my
homie your homie and giddy up giddy up
josh
allen i mean come on that's gonna be
amazing
yeah and i don't think two teams either
team is gonna slip too far
or or anything like that all right i'm
gonna go a little off the radar here
not to like their traditional power
uh match up here but week seven
rams lions i'm a little intrigued by it
i'm gonna take it now
yeah i wanna see jared goff versus old
team his own team his old team
who sold him down the river and
basically just said we don't think
you're good enough sorry we're taking
matt stafford
we've had enough in fact we're so sick
of you we're gonna give the other team a
first round pick so we don't have to pay
for you anymore
and you know the comments of michael
brockers who's now on detroit with jared
gaw
i don't know there's just some some
familiarity within the organizations um
that's when i look forward to just see
the reaction of that game
that is a game where i hope that
multiple members of the rams
defense have microphones on them
because i want to hear what aaron donald
is saying to you
yeah right right i want to hear what
jalen ramsey is
saying to jared goff i don't know that
it's going to be a very good game
but it will have some drama heading into
it all right i i
you're going to be you're going to be
upset with me for doing this but
but it is an accurate
selection it is game number 272.
we don't know what it's going to be yet
it's the last game of the season
that's got to be one of the best games
of the season it's a pre-playoff playoff
game more often than not whatever that
last game of the year is is going to be
one of the best games of the year
look at that 49er seahawks game from a
couple of years ago and everything that
was riding on it the seahawks trying to
score at the end if they do
49ers aren't the number one seed
probably aren't going to the super bowl
so that last game of the year to end an
18-week season
that that is going to be whatever it is
whoever the teams are it's going to be
one of the best games of the year
you are a piece of work i'll tell you
you are i'm a piece of something yeah
you're a pain in my butt is what you are
i do you like it or do you not like it i
don't like it
absolutely not you started off the show
being cranky and now you're ending off
the show with a bullcrap third round
pick in the draft
i mean what the hell is wrong with you
okay i don't know what i don't know
there's a lot so i don't have enough
time to dive into that right now um all
right i'm stuck between two here i
in the 49ers packers sunday night
football game is very intriguing because
of all the things that have gone on this
off season
i'm gonna do one a little different
though i'm gonna do something like a
little
just nostalgic and i i i'm picturing the
future of the
this this cozy day and watching
traditional powers
christmas day oh the browns and baker
mayfield
go to see aaron rodgers and the green
bay packers in the frozen tundra
christmas day
browns packers like old
traditional nfl powers every i mean i
don't know that just
screams december holiday football i'm
gonna sit my butt on the couch and eat a
lot of food all day and watch that game
that that one just from the the
everything around it i'm excited for it
yeah you know that that will be a great
game there's two games in all
on christmas this year it's a saturday
and i think the nfl
has now realized that it can as long as
it can
fit within the broader
nfl schedule you've still got two weeks
left after christmas
whether it's saturday sunday monday
tuesday
i mean can ca i think they can find a
way
i i'm with you they can find a way with
creative use of buys
now do you want to give someone a buy
that late in the year so they can play
on wednesday if it's christmas i just
think christmas is going to become a
thing for the nfl where we're going to
see
every day of the week with the exception
maybe of wednesday but i think they can
pull it off every other day of the week
i would hope so i mean you know we
talked about this last year with the
pandemic and everything
it proved to us it's certainly possible
and yeah i mean the poor schedule maker
he probably has no hair left on his head
right now but that'll just be one thing
more you have to worry about yeah you'd
have to get creative with the buys like
you're talking about and everything that
way
uh but but i i i'm a believer after last
season that i know
i loved watching you know
thursday night sunday monday and then
tuesday night football the week
we had it was was great it really
changed the week for me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports